somehow some way you will find what you
came looking for
[Music]
this an American Idol contestant in
tears as her young daughter watches her
tough audition I think you naturally get
really
um emotionally tied to these kids and
their struggles and their Journeys
viewers saw that firsthand Sunday night
as 22 year old fire Wilmore a single mom
and stripper entered the judges room hi
what's your name
[Music]
Maja Fontano oh my
oh Mike my daughter's almost four years
old she's a handful but she's also my
best friend do you want to come sit up
here with us while mommy sings Come on
right here this way as Maja takes her
seat with Katie Lionel Richie and Luke
Bryan her mama performs Talking to the
Moon by Bruno Mars
[Music]
sit by myself
Talking to the Moon
Katie make some suggestions have you
fire hit some more powerful notes but it
wasn't enough for Lionel and Luke not
quite enough fire I'm sorry it's a no
for me I fire gosh I'm so sorry uh it's
going to be a no for me
things then take a heartbreaking turn as
Maja grabs a golden ticket to Hollywood
during her mom's rejection I think you
found this
[Music]
oh
but it's not the end of the road for
fire Katie's giving her a second chance
at the still to air Nashville auditions
that's where you're going to show us
what the what the fire is okay I know
you didn't name yourself that for
nothing
she's coming to Nashville fantastic we
support them we nurture them we give
them constructive criticism and they're
really entering into a a university as
Lionel likes to put a a crash course a
fast pace crash course of the music
industry and so we we just like teach
them everything we know in all of our
years and even if they don't win
American Idol they come back like I mean
they go home just like full of so much
hope I need to do this for me I need to
do this for my daughter
[Music]